where is the darkest part of a shadow I
mean the obvious answer seems to be
right in the middle if you look closely
at a shadow as you move the object away
from the wall you'll notice that the
shadow gets a bit fuzzy so clearly the
edges are lighter now we know that light
bends around corners that's a phenomenon
called diffraction
so is it diffraction that's responsible
for the fuzzy edges of shadows actually
no the reason that shadows have fuzzy
edges is because most light sources like
the Sun are not perfectly point objects
so light from one edge of the Sun is
coming in at a very slightly different
angle from light from the other edge of
the Sun and that's what gives us these
fuzzy edges it's not diffraction but
diffraction can play a significant role
in shadows and in fact it was the cause
of a massive debate about 200 years ago
in 1818 the French Academy sponsored a
competition to try to find the best
explanation of diffraction and Augustine
fernell entered this competition with
the suggestion that light is a wave
phenomenon and just like any ordinary
wave it bends as it passes around an
obstacle but one of the judges was
Sameach moi saw a harsh critic of the
wave theory he much preferred Newton's
idea that light was a stream of
particles and to show just how
ridiculous the wave theory was he showed
that Fornells theory would predict a
bright spot in the shadow right in the
middle of the shadow behind a circular
object that there would be a spot almost
as bright as if the object wasn't there
at all and he thought this was absurd
but my question is does it exist
is the brightest part of a shadow really
in the middle to find out we're going to
have to do the experiment so first I had
to find some circular obstacles I
selected spheres instead I got some
marbles and some small spherical magnets
then for a powerful light source and a
large distance to the screen I selected
a lecture theatre with a projector and
the first thing we're going to need is a
small aperture for the light to pass
through
and so I'm going to poke a hole in this
card with screw it's important to have a
small aperture because you want the
light to be in-phase and that should
work if it's all coming out of this
small little aperture but when I put a
sphere in front of it alright let me hit
the Lights
here we go I can't see a bright spot I
can't see anything so next I tried a
cellphone flashlight putting a marble in
front of that and again I could see
nothing I don't see anything in the
middle
the idea with Poisson spot is that light
should diffract around a circular object
or a sphere and because the center of
the shadow is equidistant from all the
edges of that obstacle all of the light
should constructively interfere at that
point creating that bright spot so next
I tried an overhead projector I tried a
string of the small spherical magnets
it's weird like I feel like I can see it
doing you can see a bright spot in the
middle of the bottom one no no I feel
like in the very center of each one I
can see a bright spot oh I don't know my
eyes is totally going nuts up here
like staring at shadows and trying to
see what we want but this one is opaque
it's nice and spherical set it down and
if I suggest the focus
you can see there is a bright spot right
in the middle of that marble so the spot
looks pretty good but something about it
didn't sit right with me and you know
when you think something is true you
really should try as hard as you can to
disprove it what if you used your
fingers to kind of make the edges less
spherical yeah you know that's that I
think is concerning the fact that we can
still see a bit of spot even though it
looks like here right how is the light
getting through and getting there was
really happening was light was coming up
from the base of this overhead projector
bouncing off this lens back onto the top
of the marble and then back up through
this lens and onto the wall so finally I
decided to use a laser I resisted doing
this earlier because in 1818 they didn't
have lasers in fact Poisson didn't do
the experiment he didn't think that you
needed to the idea of a bright spot in
the middle of a shadow was just so
ridiculous and for now didn't do the
experiment either but one of the other
judges by the name of err ago decided to
actually do the experiment and when he
did it he saw something similar to what
I saw so here I was using the laser
through a diverging lens and then that
beam was Sean onto a marble resting on
top of a loop of tape so you can see on
the wall basically exactly what you'd
expect just a shadow of the marble but
when you turn the lights off there it is
a bright spot right in the middle of
that shadow so the brightest part of a
shadow is in the middle as long as it's
the shadow of a circular or spherical
object now this spot is sometimes called
ergo spot because he did the experiment
and found it sometimes it's called
Fornells bright spot because it was his
theory but pretty frequently it's
referred to as Posen's
spot a harsh reminder that is not only
your great achievements but also your
greatest mistakes
can be named after you we don't see puss
on spot in our day-to-day lives for many
reasons one of which is that most
objects are not perfect circle's plus if
they have any surface roughness really
at all that will completely wash out
Poisson spot and finally most light
sources are not coherent that is the
waves are not coming all in phase peaks
with peaks and troughs with troughs so
you might think you could never see
Poisson spot under ordinary conditions
but you can what you need to do is look
at a diffuse source of bright light like
a fluorescent tube or the blue sky you
should see some small light specks
drifting around your visual field now
those are caused by floaters little
particles actually drifting around
inside your eyeball they can be all
sorts of different shapes but some of
them are spheres and so they cast a
shadow on the back of your retina and
right in the middle of that shadow is
pasand bright spot and that is what
demonstrated that light really is a wave
phenomenon and you don't even have to
take my word for it you can see it with
your very own eyes
you
you